there is a new report that the Trump
administration is sending babies and
other young children to so-called
tender-age shelters and that is fueling
new outrage over its border policy The
Associated Press reports the government
is housing these young children in at
least three special detention facilities
in South Texas tender-age is typically
defined as 12 and under by the
Department of Homeland Security
Houston's mayor says the administration
plans to open an another tender age
shelter in that city
CBS San Antonio affiliate ke & S reports
some of these young children are being
housed in Brownsville Texas so David beg
no traveled there overnight David good
morning John good morning the building
is called Casa El Presidente now we
haven't been inside it to see for
ourselves we tried to ask some questions
but a worker told us this morning I
can't confirm to you whether kids here
have been separated from their parents
look we have been trying to get a
real-life assessment of how detentions
are happening at the border so we went
on a ride-along with Border Patrol we
got two hours and we saw 16 people
detain some people took off running
others surrendered here's more of what
we witnessed Raul Ortiz deputy chief for
the Rio Grande Valley sector in South
Texas wanted us to see the exact spot
where he says more people enter the US
illegally than anywhere else along the
border it's near McAllen have you gone a
day on the job where you didn't
encounter someone crossing illegally no
I haven't Ortiz told us people will
enter illegally even if they see the
Border Patrol waiting on them even if
that means coming right into your arms
yes and your handcuffs most definitely
yeah it's worth the risk for them it is
worth the risk it was worth it for this
family of five from Honduras they told
us they left on a bus several months ago
and were trying to get to Dallas hello
my name is David
what is your name Yolanda's daughter
Angie is 8 months old that's her brother
her sister and her mom Maria chief Ortiz
says Maria told him the family was
escaping violence in Honduras and they
knew the risk they were taking even
though you're going to be detained is it
worth it to you anyway her answer was
translated by Border Patrol agent Sergio
Tinoco everybody knows that there's help
for families here in the United States
and so the risk is valid to them I can
sense the empathy in your voice what
goes through your mind when you come
upon a group of people like this well
this is for all of us I mean all of us
are from this area we all grew up here I
grew up here we're all human nonetheless
but we still have to do our job that
meant temporarily seizing their
belongings and loading them onto a bus
headed for a processing center 30
minutes later chief Ortiz told us a
group of men were running from his
agents he took us to the scene jumped
out and gave chase catching one of the
suspects in all 13 men allegedly ran
through this orchard using bushes as
cover only five were captured searched
handcuffed and taken away they were
taken to a processing facility about ten
minutes away and that is where they are
read their Miranda rights
now Gael that Honduran family we just
mentioned in the piece they will not be
separated according to chief Ortiz that
is because they all traveled as a family
unit and there is that young baby that
eight month old so he's saying that
family won't be separated but that same
guarantee is not passed along to other
families like them
all right David thank you very much